Okay guys, it's great to be here. I'm really happy that we get to do the podcast today. It's our final smart list ever. Very special smart list. Don't say that. People are going to think that. Let's finish strong and this guest is really what a great final guest. Our final episode. It's not final. It's not final. It's not ever.
好吧，各位，很高兴来到这里。我真的很高兴我们今天能做这个播客。这是我们有史以来最后一期 SmartLess。非常特别的一期 SmartLess。别这么说。人们会胡思乱想的。让我们有个完美的收尾，这位嘉宾真的是一位多么棒的最终嘉宾啊。我们的最后一集。这不是最后一集。这不是最后一集。这绝不是最后一集。
Wait, it's not our final episode? Let us finish. No. For today. For today is our final episode. It will be our last. Sean, don't cut us off, rude. For today, but for today.
等等，这不是我们的最后一集吗？让我们说完。不。就今天而言。就今天是我们的最后一集。这将是我们的最后一次。肖恩，别打断我们，真粗鲁。就今天而言，但就今天。
For today, this is our final, final smart list. Ever. Ever. But not today. For today. Sean with the cutting off. Welcome to smart list. Smart.
就今天而言，这是我们最后最后的一次 SmartLess。有史以来。有史以来。但不是今天。就今天而言。肖恩又在打断别人。欢迎来到 SmartLess。Smart。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
Smart. The new small list. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart。全新的小列表。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。
I put the due and douche. Wait. It'll be our first line of this episode. Right there. We just found our end. I put the due and douche. That's not good for me. Wait a second.
I put the due and douche。等一下。这将是我们这集的第一句台词。就在那儿。我们刚刚找到了结尾。I put the due and douche。这对我可不太好。等一下。
Wait, will jokes over when you come in home? I know. Soon, right? End of this week, maybe? Yeah, end of this week. I'm actually really looking forward to it. You were gonna come home a little early. Weren't you threatening to do that?
等等，等你回家的时候笑话就结束了吧？我知道。快了吧，对吧？这周末结束时，也许吧？对，这周末结束。我其实真的很期待。你本来打算早点回来的。你不是一直在威胁要这么做吗？
Yeah, I was. First of all, how, Jason, when were you here? Remember you were gonna come and you called me? I was gonna come, but- And then you never followed up. The dude came here. No way. The dude came here, yeah.
对，我是。首先，杰森，你是怎么回事，你什么时候来过？还记得你本来要来，然后你给我打电话吗？我本打算去的，但是——然后你就不了了之了。那家伙来这儿了。不可能。那家伙来这儿了，对。
What are you talking about? So, Sean, are you, did I tell you this when I saw you? What did I see you yesterday? Are you sure, can we talk about this? Wait, did I see you yesterday? I saw you yesterday. No, I saw you Saturday. Saturday, Saturday.
你在说什么呢？所以，肖恩，你，我昨天见你时跟你说过这个吗？我昨天是什​​么时候见你的？你确定吗，我们能谈谈这个吗？等等，我昨天见你了吗？我昨天见你了。不对，我是星期六见你的。星期六，星期六。
I talked to Sean last night. I phoned, I face- You phoned him, granddad? Face-time bombed him. That was really funny. Oh my God, they were freaking out. Anyway, keep going. He was with a bunch of, he was with lesbians.
我昨晚跟肖恩聊过。我打电——你给他视频——你给他打电话了，老爷子？Face-time轰炸了他。那真的太搞笑了。哦，天哪，他们当时吓坏了。不管怎样，继续。他跟一群人在一起，他跟女同性恋在一起。
And I was like, yeah, you don't have to tell me they're lesbians. I got it. He did tell them. Let's go deeper on that, could we have names? Wait, Jason, tell me what we're gonna say. So, I don't know if I can talk. Well, I guess I can talk about this.
然后我说，好吧，你不用告诉我她们是女同性恋。我明白了。他确实告诉她们了。我们深入聊聊这个，能说出名字吗？等等，杰森，告诉我我们要说什么。所以，我不知道我能不能说。好吧，我想我可以谈谈这个。
I can just kind of skid along the top of it. My eldest, my 15-year-old daughter. We talked a little bit about this, but keep going. Yeah, so she went to Europe this summer in a camp and she fell in love. And this guy, he lives in New York. He is currently married, has three kids, but, you know. She, but you can always work it out.
我可以稍微掠过表面。我的大女儿，我15岁的女儿。我们之前稍微聊过一点这个，但继续吧。对，所以她今年夏天去了欧洲的一个夏令营，然后她恋爱了。这个男孩子，他住在纽约。他目前已婚，有三个孩子，不过呢。她，不过你总能把事情解决的。
You can work through it. So, she loves him. No, he's her age, he's 15, and she was going to fly out there and see him in New York because they'd been done with camp for a couple of weeks and she was starting to really miss him. This whipper snapper gets a hold of my wife
你能克服困难的。所以，她爱他。不，他跟她同龄，15岁，她本打算飞去纽约看他，因为他们夏令营结束已经好几周了，她开始非常想念他。这个毛头小子居然联系了我老婆
and works out a whole surprise to come out and see Franny and visit and surprise Franny. So, this guy's been here posting up in my house for three days and just extended his trip another three days as of today. It was a surprise, it was a surprise. He's there now. Yeah, here now.
然后策划了一个大惊喜，要来看弗兰尼并拜访她，给弗兰尼一个惊喜。所以，这家伙已经在我家待了三天了，截至今天，他又把行程延长了三天。这是一个惊喜，这是一个惊喜。他现在就在那儿。对，现在在这儿。
And he's staying with you. Staying with us. There's rules, there's rules. There's rules, he's an angel though. He clearly needs no rules. He just, he seems to drop straight from heaven. Nice kid. But tell Will what you did to keep the surprise from Franny.
而且他住在你家。住在我们家。有规矩，有规矩。有规矩，不过他像个天使。他显然不需要什么规矩。他只是，他看起来像是直接从天上掉下来的一样。不错的孩子。不过告诉威尔你是怎么瞒着弗兰尼的。
Oh, well, you know, it was a whole thing about like, well, him landing and then, you know, getting a ride to the house and then do we, do we have her, you know, like run into him in a coffee shop? Here, no, next to the house, or should we have him just kind of be in the house and have her come downstairs? And, you know, Amanda and I were trying to think. Jump out of the cake.
哦，嗯，你知道的，这整件事包括，比如，他落地后，然后，你知道的，搭车到家里，然后我们是，我们要让她，你知道的，在咖啡馆里跟他偶遇吗？在这里，不，就在房子旁边，还是应该让他直接在家里，然后让她下楼？而且，你知道的，阿曼达和我在想。从蛋糕里跳出来。
Well, yeah, come out, yeah. We didn't want to. Here, just getting this cake. I was really set on trying to preserve the moment that she sees him that we're not, you know, having, you know, two cameras rolling and making sure, because, you know, of course that's what we want and that's what his mom wants.
嗯，对，出来，对。我们不想。在这里，就弄这个蛋糕。我真的很想保留她看到他时的那一刻，我们不要，你知道的，安排，你知道的，两台摄像机同时拍摄并确保，因为，你知道的，这当然是我们的愿望，也是他妈妈的愿望。
But anyway, we kind of, we kind of did a little of each and I think it was a big success. You told her to kind of get gussied up for a photo or something? Oh yeah, because Amanda thought, well, gosh, you know, if I was surprised and I didn't look my best, I'd be upset at whoever surprised me. So Amanda said that she had to like,
但无论如何，我们，我们两样都做了一点，我认为非常成功。你让她为了拍照什么的稍微打扮了一下？哦，对，因为阿曼达觉得，天哪，你知道的，如果我被吓了一跳，而且我没有呈现出最好的一面，我会生那个给我惊喜的人的气。所以阿曼达说她必须——
she had to get like her passport picture retaken or some sort of picture that the photographer was nice enough to come over to the house. And so just make sure you comb your hair before you come downstairs kind of. Yeah, wow. Yeah, it was really, really cool. I love that story.
她必须去重新拍一张护照照片，或者某种摄影师非常友善地来到家里拍的照片。所以就是那种“下楼前一定要把头发梳好”的感觉。对，哇。对，真的，真的很酷。我喜欢这个故事。
It's so sweet. Yeah. If you have video, you'll show me video, Amanda. We've got video. So you did shoot it. You filmed it with a crew. We did film it, but it was at a tasteful distance. Full crew from Discovery.
太甜了。对。如果你有视频，你会给我看视频的，阿曼达。我们有视频。所以你确实拍下来了。你带了一个摄制组拍摄的。我们确实拍了，但保持了有品味的距离。来自探索频道的完整摄制组。
I had done. Have you ever seen a loan? It's the same production crew that shoot, that works on a loan. Wouldn't be nice shout out for a loan. Will, have you gotten into a loan frozen yet? Dude, I am in a loan. We took a break for, I'm now in a loan,
我做过。你看过《独行侠》（Alone）吗？就是拍摄、参与制作《独行侠》的那个制作团队。真该给《独行侠》大声欢呼一下。威尔，你迷上《独行侠：冰冻求生》（Alone Frozen）了吗？老兄，我正在看《独行侠》。我们休息了一会儿，我现在在看《独行侠》，
the first one where they do couples. Yeah, so you met your Canadian guys. How about those Canadian girls? Are those guys not the best? I gotta watch this. But they are such graduates of Hoser U, they're from Toronto. And the one of them says to his brother, he goes,
第一部有夫妻参加的那季。对，所以你遇到了那些加拿大老兄。那些加拿大姑娘怎么样？那些家伙难道不是最棒的吗？我得看看这个。但他们简直是“加拿大傻瓜大学”（Hoser U）的优秀毕业生，他们来自多伦多。其中一个人对他的兄弟说，他去——
and I noticed the casual swearing by Canadians is so off the charts that nobody gets beat more on those shows than Canadians. He'd be like, fuck it, hell of a day, eh? So it's just, be hell of a day, eh? I'm just like, oh, these guys are, they're beauts. The guy goes, he's fishing, he's like, fuck, I better catch something or I'm just gonna
我注意到加拿大人随口说脏话的频率简直爆表，在那些节目里，没有人比加拿大人挨的整更多了。他会说：“操，真是美好的一天，哈？”所以就是，美好的一天，哈？我当时就想，哦，这些家伙，他们真是极品。那家伙去钓鱼，他说：“操，我最好能抓到点什么，否则我真要在自己脸上捅一刀了，哈？”
stab myself in the face, eh? I forget how far they make it, but- It's so, it's so good. When are you talking about the new one? It's like a loan frozen. No, no, no, that's season nine. He's not there yet. I'm past that and now going to start the spin-off.
我忘了他们撑了多久，但——太棒了，太棒了。你什么时候聊新的一季？就像《独行侠：冰冻求生》。不，不，不，那是第九季。他还没到那儿。我过了那一季，现在开始看衍生节目了。
The ex-champions that they drop into a frozen tundra. This is called a loan frozen. I haven't started yet, but I've got a couple episodes all banked off. Oh, wait, by the way, I, speaking of gussing yourself up, I got a facial the other day and the woman, when I'm done, she says, by the way, Will, it's the same spot that I got you a gift card for.
把前冠军们空投到冰冻苔原。这叫《独行侠：冰冻求生》。我还没开始看，但我已经攒了好几集了。哦，对了，顺便说一句，我，说到打扮自己，我前几天做了个面部护理，然后那个女人，当我做完时，她说，顺便说一句，威尔，这和我送你礼品券的地方是同一家。
Wait, how often? Will has six jokes already. Just write off the word facial. I meant about facial. Yeah, which is just, she's in my face. Boy, you love a facial, eh? She's in my face. Did you, did you, you gave a facial or you got one?
等等，多久一次？威尔已经有六个笑话了。就删掉“面部护理”（facial）这个词吧。我指的是关于面部护理的。对，就是，她在我的天灵盖上。天哪，你可真喜欢做面部护理，哈？她在我的脸上。你，你，你做了一个面部护理还是你得到了一个？
I can't conclude. Sorry, I don't know what joke to use. I don't know, there's no way to joke. Okay, so wait. Wait, Sean, so you go, you get a facial? I got a facial. And when I was done, the woman says, the woman says, your scalp is too tight.
我无法下结论。对不起，我不知道该用哪个笑话。我不知道，根本没法开玩笑。好吧，等等。等等，肖恩，所以你去做了个面部护理？我做了一个面部护理。当我做完的时候，那个女人说，那个女人说，你的头皮太紧了。
Wow, good for you. Yeah. Stop seeing them up, Sean, you gotta be quicker. Jason, stop laughing, because when I was done, she says to me, I mean, drop the ellipses and keep our neck out. Okay, ready? Yeah, yeah. When I was done, the woman turns to me and says,
哇，那可真好。好了，别再铺垫了，肖恩，你得反应快点。杰森，别笑了，因为当我做完的时候，她对我说——呃，去掉省略号，别让我们出丑。好吧，准备好了吗？对，对。当我做完的时候，那个女人转身对我说，
your scalp is too tight, you think too much. And I said, sorry, excuse me. She says, you need to stop thinking so hard. And I'm like, what does that even mean? You must have got a real deal on her. I had a, I did not have a facial today or give one, but I did, I did have a, like a face, what did they call it?
你的头皮太紧了，你脑子里想得太多了。我说，对不起，劳驾。她说，你需要停止想得那么多。我说，那到底是什么意思？你在她那儿肯定拿到了超级优惠。我今天没有做面部护理，也没有给别人做，但我确实，我确实做了一个，像面部，他们叫什么来着？
Like face gym or something, this person comes and they like, it was, I was sort of set it up and they did this thing and they like manipulated my face and moved it all around, did all this stuff. It was incredible. A face gym, so like, like cheek push ups and things like that. Yeah, they come, they do all this stuff and then with this electromagnetic thing,
比如面部健身（face gym）什么的，这个人过来然后他们就像，这是我安排的，他们做了这个东西，然后他们像操纵我的脸一样把它四处移动，做了所有这些事情。这太不可思议了。面部健身，就像——像脸颊俯卧撑之类的事情。对，他们过来，做所有这些事情，然后用这种电磁设备，
they do all this stuff and it was like, I've never had it. I've had three facials, I think, in my life. They were great, but I just forget. It's nice, they're nice. I forget to do it. They're nice because you know. Your skin looks very, Sean, you look very good. Well, you look good.
他们做了所有这些事情，就像——我从来没做过。我这辈子大概做过三次面部护理。它们很棒，但我总是忘记。挺好的，它们挺好的。我忘了去做了。它们挺好的，因为你知道的。你的皮肤看起来很好，肖恩，你看起来非常好。嗯，你看起来不错。
You look great. I only fill out a V-neck mask. I'm currently in a relationship, so. Well, but you're coming out here, right? You coming out, you changing area codes? Okay, so wait guys, before we get to our guests, I have an official announcement. Oh boy, is it facial related?
你看起来棒极了。我只穿V领毛衣。我目前在谈恋爱，所以。嗯，不过你要来这里对吧？你要来这里，你要换区号吗？好吧，各位，在我们请出嘉宾之前，我有一个官方公告。哦，天哪，跟面部护理有关吗？
What's that? What did you say? I asked if it was facial related. No, it's not. I got Will Mid-Sip, yeah. No, it's not facial related. Okay, so the play I did at the Goodman Theater in Chicago earlier this year, it's called Good Night Oscar.
什么？你刚才说什么？我问这是否跟面部护理有关。不，不是。我打断了威尔喝水，对。不，不是面部护理相关的。好吧，所以我今年早些时候在芝加哥古德曼剧院（Goodman Theater）演的那部戏剧，叫《晚安，奥斯卡》（Good Night Oscar）。
This is the official, official announcement that it's going to Broadway. No way. Yes, performances begin April 7th. Oh wow. If you go to GoodnightOscar.com, that's GoodnightOscar.com. Spell it.
这是官方的、绝对官方的公告，它要登陆百老汇了。不会吧。是的，4月7日开始演出。哦，哇。如果你去 GoodnightOscar.com，那就是 GoodnightOscar.com。拼出来。
Spell it. G-O-O-D-N-I-G-E-H-T-S-O-S-C-I. It's not K-N-I, because this is the sword play you're doing, right? No, it's like good morning, good night. You'll be one of the first to get tickets if you go to GoodnightOscar.com. Tickets go on sale today.
拼出来。G-O-O-D-N-I-G-H-T-S-O-S-C-I。不是 K-N-I，因为这不是你在演的剑术表演，对吧？不，就像早上好，晚上好。如果你去 GoodnightOscar.com，你将是第一批买到票的人之一。门票今天开售。
Today. So I hope you call and get excellent seats. It's a great show. Good Night Oscar. Wow, that's great. And this is not the Excalibur one act you were doing. No, it's not. And it's going to open at the Bellasco Theater, which is huge, and it's great theater, and I heard it's a little haunted.
今天。所以我希望你们打电话去买到绝佳的座位。这是一部很棒的演出。《晚安，奥斯卡》。哇，太棒了。这可不是你演的那个《神剑游侠》（Excalibur）独幕剧吧。不，不是。它将在贝拉斯科剧院（Bellasco Theater）开幕，那个剧院非常大，而且是一个很棒的剧院，我听说它稍微有点闹鬼。
So that's going to be exciting. That is great. Congratulations, Shawnee. Thank you, I'm excited. I'm afraid of no ghosts, by the way, should be mentioned. No, but Shawnee, congratulations. He had a very successful run in Chicago listener, and he has earned this.
所以那会很令人兴奋。太棒了。恭喜你，肖尼。谢谢，我很兴奋。顺便提一句，我什么鬼魂都不怕。不，但是肖尼，恭喜你。他在芝加哥的演出非常成功，这是他应得的。
So I'm going to go out there and I'm going to see it. Will, are you still thinking about it? Up in the air, up in the air. About going to see it? Yeah, and we don't want your matinee money. I always came to Chicago, and I couldn't do it in the one week I had in Atlanta. Anyway, yes, I'm going to be there.
所以我打算去那里看。威尔，你还在考虑吗？悬而未决，悬而未决。关于去看演出？对，我们可不想要你的日场门票。我以前去过芝加哥，但在亚特兰大的唯一一周我抽不出时间。不管怎样，是的，我会去的。
Are you kidding? We'll carpool. Thank you, guys, for being so supportive. I'm excited for you. So happy for you, Shawnee. All right, guys, so our guest today, boy, does she make me laugh a lot. But funny enough, that's not what she gets paid the big bucks to do. She was signed to a major record label at just 15 years old.
开玩笑吗？我们拼车去。谢谢大家的支持。我为你感到兴奋。为你感到高兴，肖尼。好了，各位，今天的嘉宾，天哪，她总是能让我捧腹大笑。但有趣的是，这并不是她拿高薪的原因。她15岁时就与一家主流唱片公司签约了。
Oh my god. She eventually released her first album under a different name than what we know her as today. Jackson. The self-titled album was heavily influenced by her Christian upbringing, which I'm going to ask about, too. She celebrated in the LGBTQ community, winning many awards for advocacy and philanthropy. Guys like me have some pretty bad ass empowerment anthems because of her strength.
哦，天哪。她最终以一个与我们今天所知不同的名字发行了她的第一张专辑。杰克逊。这张同名专辑深受她基督教成长背景的影响，我也打算问问这件事。她在 LGBTQ 社区备受赞誉，因倡导和慈善事业赢得了许多奖项。像我这样的人因为她的坚强而拥有了一些非常厉害的赋权赞歌。
Please welcome the fantastic, the fabulous, Katy Perry. What? Katy, Katy Perry. That was a long wait for you, Katy. That was a long wait. You don't have to wait that long for anything. Katy, you don't have to wait that long. You could have just hung up on us.
请欢迎这位了不起的、极好的凯蒂·佩里（Katy Perry）。什么？凯蒂，凯蒂·佩里。凯蒂，你等了很久才出场。等了很久。你做什么都不用等那么久。凯蒂，你不用等那么久的。你大可以直接挂断我们的电话。
Did you hear me cracking my knuckles? I was like, guys, my child just woke up from a nap. She's desperate to see her mommy. Let's go. Oh, is that true? Well, not really. OK, let's get right into the baby stuff. How is the kidnapping?
你听到我捏关节的声音了吗？我当时想，伙计们，我的孩子刚刚睡醒午觉。她急着见妈妈呢。我们走吧。哦，是真的吗？嗯，其实不算。好吧，我们直接进入育儿的话题吧。绑架（指带娃）进展如何？
Boy or girl? She's a girl. She's about to be two years old. She's doing OK. But you know, I am working a lot, and I've always worked a lot, and kind of been a matriarchal figure. Yes, you have. And I have a wonderful nanny, but I
男孩还是女孩？是个女孩。她快两岁了。她挺好的。不过你知道，我工作很多，而且我一直都工作很多，有点像个大家长似的人物。是的，你确实是。我有一个很棒的保姆，但我
don't have a full-time nanny because I feel like if I had a full-time nanny, then I would never be able to know how to care for my daughter. Like I'm meant to. And so therefore, any day I get off, I'm just in mom mode. Doesn't matter if I've had a show that goes till 11 PM the night before, I'm waking up at 6 o'clock, and we're going to go and do breakfast.
没有全职保姆，因为我觉得如果我有一个全职保姆，我就永远无法学会如何像我本来应该做的那样去照顾我的女儿。所以因此，我得到的任何一天假，我都处于妈妈模式。不管我前一天晚上的演出是不是一直开到晚上11点，我早上6点都会醒来，然后我们要去吃早餐。
And yes, I have the no-sleep shakes. But yeah, so I'm doing mom mode today, and my sister tapped in to do some Play-Doh while we're having a little chat. Well, thank you for taking the time. I think as much help as you can get, just for what it's worth, it always made me a better parent so that I could refill my patients tank and my compromised
是的，我有睡眠不足带来的颤抖症。但总之，我今天处于妈妈模式，我姐姐来搭把手玩玩培乐多泥（Play-Doh），同时我们在这里聊聊天。好吧，谢谢你抽出时间。我觉得你能得到多少帮助，就值得获取多少，这总是能让我成为一个更好的父母，这样我就能重新填满我的耐心库和透支的
tank and whatever that is. I don't think help is great as much as you can get. Oh, of course. I mean, it's worth like super blessed. And I'm so grateful. But I also want to participate. And I want like she's two. So she's at that point where it's like she's
精力库，无论那是什么。我不觉得寻求帮助有什么不好的，能得到多少就尽量多得多少。哦，当然。我的意思是，这简直超级幸福。我非常感激。但我也想参与其中。而且我想——她两岁了。所以她正处于那个阶段，就是她
saying new words every day. And the other day, she was just saying some words that I didn't teach her. And I was like, damn it, that doesn't feel good. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Now, so she's two. So then she's walking around. Oh, yeah.
每天都在说新词。前几天，她说了一些我没教过她的词，我当时就想，该死，这感觉可真不好。哦，对，对，对。现在，她两岁了。所以她到处走动。哦，对。
Oh, yeah. You have all the corners padded and all that stuff. Yeah, still. I actually overheard your conversation about the new boyfriend. Yes. Yes. I think you got to look at the bright side of this,
哦，对。你把所有的桌角都包了软垫，诸如此类的。对，依然如此。我其实无意中听到你们关于那个新男友的对话。对。对。我觉得你得看到好的一面，
is that he's on your turf. She's not over there. No. Not texting me back. He's literally in your house. So if you wanted to set up that extra ring camera and throw it in like a old stuff teddy bear in the bedroom, you know, you could do it.
那就是他在你的地盘上。她没去那边。不。没有不回我信息。他简直就在你家里。所以如果你想安装那个额外的 Ring 摄像头，把它塞进卧室里一个旧泰迪熊玩具里，你知道的，你完全可以做到。
I might see stuff I don't want to see. Sure. I might see stuff I don't want to see. Now, are you getting help from dad? Yeah, dad's doing it. Of course, dad is the best. But actually, I was a little tardy for this call because he had just called me to let me know he was alive,
我可能会看到一些我不想看的东西。确实。我可能会看到一些我不想看的东西。现在，你从爸爸那里得到帮助了吗？对，爸爸在帮忙。当然，爸爸最棒了。不过其实，我接这个电话有点迟到，因为他刚刚打电话给我，让我知道他还活着，
because he's in the Bahamas right now filming a show where he goes to kind of just the edge of everything extreme. And he's doing an episode on freediving. So he just freedove like over 100 feet. For my sister, Tracy, you're talking about Orlando Bloom. Yes, Orlando Bloom, yeah. And so he was just calling me to check in and tell me that he's still around, which I'm grateful for,
因为他现在在巴哈马拍摄一个节目，在那里他去到各种极限边缘的地方。他正在拍摄一集关于自由潜水的节目。所以他刚刚自由潜水了100多英尺。为了我姐姐特蕾西，你是在说奥兰多·布鲁姆（Orlando Bloom）吗？对，奥兰多·布鲁姆，对。所以他刚才打电话给我报平安，告诉我他还在，我很感激，
because it's been a few days. He's been learning how to do all these kind of extreme sports. He's filming a show for Discovery. And it's just like, it's a little nerve-wracking. Wow, no stunt doubles allowed in that. Sean can relate. He has his own stunt. You've got to go in toes first, right?
因为已经好几天了。他一直在学习如何做所有这些极限运动。他在为探索频道拍摄一集节目。这让人有点伤脑筋。哇，那里不允许替身。肖恩对此深有同感。你得脚尖朝下跳进去，对吧？
Will used to do a lot of, in Acapulco, he did some freediving. You've got to go in toes first. You lose your toenail on that. Excuse me for that footage of me. Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure, from back in the day. And we will be right back. All right, back to the show.
威尔以前经常在阿卡普尔科做一些自由潜水。你得脚尖朝下跳进去。那样会把你的脚趾甲弄掉。请原谅我当年那些录像。对，对，对，当然，从以前开始。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。
Wait, Katie, I want to talk about, by the way, I know you have to like transfer out of like my mode for a second and be here to talk about all the stuff I want to do. I wear so many fucking hats. Come on. Yeah, come on, let's do it. All right, so I did not know your real name was Kate Hudson. Katie Hudson.
等等，凯蒂，我想谈谈，顺便说一句，我知道你得暂时切换出“妈妈模式”，来到这里谈论所有我想做的事情。我特么有那么多身份要扮演。来吧。对，来吧，我们开始吧。好吧，我不知道你的真名是凯特·哈德森（Kate Hudson）。凯蒂·哈德森（Katie Hudson）。
Well, yeah, it's Catherine Hudson. Yeah, it's, but people called me Katie Hudson. But in the beginning, I decided not to do that because. How did you settle on Perry? My mother's made a name Perry. So if we were living in a matriarchal society, it would have just been easy. Have you cornered Kate Hudson at a party
嗯，对，是凯瑟琳·哈德森（Catherine Hudson）。对，是这样，但人们叫我凯蒂·哈德森。但在开始的时候，我决定不这么做，因为。你是怎么定下“佩里”（Perry）这个姓的？我母亲的娘家姓是佩里。所以如果我们生活在一个母系社会，这就很简单了。你有没有在派对上把凯特·哈德森逼到角落里，
and told her to back off and to give you the name back? No, we're best friends. We get along, and that was actually the first thing that we got along on, but she's. How could you not get along with her? She's just, I don't know first. Afro-Vethant is the word, I think. Yeah, she's so sweet.
然后叫她靠边站，把名字还给你？不，我们是最好的朋友。我们相处得很好，这实际上是我们最开始合得来的原因，但她。你怎么可能跟她合不来呢？她只是，我不知道该怎么形容。Afro-Vethant（注：此处凯蒂口误或造词）这个词，我想是吧。对，她太温柔了。
She's just like, I can do anything. I've got children. I can cook. I'll show you how to do my yoga pose. Wait, speaking of poses, the first time I met you was very brief backstage at either Madonna or Janet Jackson. I can't remember. But I think it was probably Madonna.
她就像是——我什么都能做。我有孩子。我会做饭。我来教你怎么做我的瑜伽姿势。等等，说到姿势，我第一次见你非常短暂，是在麦当娜或珍妮·杰克逊的后台。我不记得了。但我猜可能是麦当娜。
Madonna. And I didn't stick around because Madonna was like two, three hours late. I was like, I'm old. I got to go to bed. I get it. But I saw you backstage, and the first time we didn't even say hello, I go, Katie, you go, Sean.
麦当娜。我没有多留，因为麦当娜迟到了两三小时。我当时想，我都老了。我得去睡觉了。我懂。但我在后台看到你，我们第一次甚至都没有打招呼，我说：“凯蒂”，你说：“肖恩”。
And we both did the lion's pose because we have the same vocal coach. Oh, yeah. Remember that? We stuck our hands up like that. Eric Vitro, shout out. Eric Vitro, yeah. He's the greatest.
然后我们俩都摆出了狮子式瑜伽姿势，因为我们有同一个声乐教练。哦，对。还记得吗？我们把手举成那样。埃里克·维特罗（Eric Vitro），大声喊出他的名字。埃里克·维特罗，对。他是最棒的。
The most iconic, he's like kind of like, he's Corky St. Clair in a Christopher Guest movie. He really is, he's like a little, he's like a character from Christopher Guest movie. He's the greatest, and the greatest vocal coach ever. Got me through Broadway. He's amazing. If I had his name, I would call my business in Vitro, of course.
最具标志性，他有点像——他就像克里斯托弗·格斯特（Christopher Guest）电影里的科基·圣克莱尔（Corky St. Clair）。他真的，他就像克里斯托弗·格斯特电影里的一个角色。他是最棒的，也是史上最棒的声乐教练。带我度过了百老汇时期。他太惊艳了。如果我有他的名字，我当然会把我的公司叫作“In Vitro（试管婴儿）”。
How would you not? Of course. Of course. How the fuck would you not? Wait a second, wait a second. So Sean came up to you at a after a concert. And then did the. No, before.
你怎么会不这么叫？当然。当然。特么的你怎么会不这么叫？等一下，等一下。所以肖恩在演唱会结束后向你走过去。然后做了那个。不，是在之前。
Oh, before the concert. And were you on your, so you went to Janet Jackson, and then were you on your way to share? Or was that? The Holy Trinity? Yeah. You mean the Holy Trinity? The Trinity was complete with Katie there.
哦，在演唱会之前。你当时是，所以你去了珍妮·杰克逊的演唱会，然后你是在去看雪儿（Cher）的路上？还是那是？圣三位一体？对。你是说圣三位一体？随着凯蒂的到来，三位一体就完整了。
Sean, you know that Katie doesn't know that I was actually a backup dancer for Janet Jackson. Will was on an episode of Will and Grace, where we were both backup dancers to Janet Jackson. Sean and I had to dance off, and I was in the Jackson band. Jason, you were there that night. Yeah. I was there.
肖恩，你知道凯蒂不知道我其实是珍妮·杰克逊的伴舞吗？威尔曾出演过一集《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace），我们在里面都是珍妮·杰克逊的伴舞。肖恩和我不得不进行舞蹈对决，而我在杰克逊的乐队里。杰森，那天晚上你在场。对。我在场。
So true story. Wait, go back to just for one second with Eric Vitro. Do you still use him and call him up? Because you're doing a Vegas show. Is it every night you do the Vegas show? No, I do it in like three week installments. How much you get for that? How much money do they pay you for that?
所以这是个真实的故事。等等，回到埃里克·维特罗身上，就一秒钟。你现在还找他并打电话给他吗？因为你在做拉斯维加斯的驻场演出。你是在拉斯维加斯每晚都演吗？不，我是以大约三周为一期来演的。你为此赚多少钱？他们为此付给你多少钱？
You don't have to answer that. Don't listen to him. It allows me the ability to drop my daughter off at preschool, and then mommy goes to work and comes back home the next day. So it's like, it's such a great routine, you know? It's like, it's something that like pop stars love to do and check off the box.
你不用回答这个。别听他的。这让我能够把女儿送到学前班，然后妈妈去上班，第二天回家。所以这就像是一个非常棒的常规作息，你知道吗？这就像是流行巨星们喜欢做并打勾完成的事情。
But it's also, I get to create an incredible crazy, crazy show that I can't tour with because I couldn't possibly move all these absurd props that are on the stage. But do I call him every single time I sing? No, I actually have a recording. Yeah, I do too. Yeah, and it's like from like 10 years ago. Yeah, it's the best.
但这也是我得以创作一场令人难以置信的、疯狂的演出的机会，我无法带着它去巡演，因为我根本不可能搬运舞台上所有这些荒谬的道具。但我每次唱歌都会给他打电话吗？不，我其实有个录音。对，我也是。对，而且大概是10年前的。对，这太棒了。
Do you know, so you know Eric Vito, do you know Scevo? That's Sean's beautician. We all know each other. This community, we're all just, we just all hang. All right, so in Vegas, so you do three weeks at a time at your, what is the place? What is the venue? It's at Resorts World.
你知道，既然你认识埃里克·维特罗，你认识斯切沃（Scevo）吗？那是肖恩的美容师。我们都认识彼此。这个圈子里，我们所有人，我们只是经常一起聚聚。好吧，所以在拉斯维加斯，你每次在你的地方演出三周，那是哪里？场地是什么？是在度假村世界（Resorts World）。
Resorts World. Which is the newest hotel on this trip. Gotcha. And it's right next to the win. And I started it out on New Year's Eve, I think, or a couple of days before New Year's Eve. Just this past year? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
度假村世界。那是这条街上最新的酒店。明白了。它就在永利酒店（Wynn）旁边。我想我是从新年前夜开始的，或者是在新年前夜前几天。就去年？对，对，对。
And I'm there for this year. And I'll be doing some more shows. I'll do my last kind of announced run so far, and it depends if we'll go next year, is in October, so. So you do three weeks on one week off, three weeks on one week off, all year until October? No, I don't do that. Actually, it's kind of crazy.
我今年也会在那儿。我还会做更多演出。我到目前为止宣布的最后一轮演出，取决于我们明年是否继续，是在十月，所以。所以你是一年里一直三周上班一周休息，三周上班一周休息，直到十月？不，我不是那样的。其实，这挺疯狂的。
It's three weeks on, and then sometimes six to nine weeks off. Oh, that's a nice thing. And it's really easy to become fat Elvis in between. Really? Incredible. So listen, Katie, I've always, this is so cool that you're here, so thank you. It is very cool to have you on this.
是演三周，然后有时休息六到九周。哦，那挺不错的。在这期间很容易变成“肥王（胖猫王）”。真的吗？难以置信。所以听着，凯蒂，我一直——你能来真是太酷了，所以谢谢你。你能来参加这个节目真的很酷。
Oh, stop. I'm only doing this because of, it's divided between Sean and Amanda. I'm gonna tell her. I'm gonna tell her. It's mostly Amanda. I love you, Sean, but Amanda, she's. No, I get it.
哦，别说了。我来这儿完全是因为，这全靠肖恩和阿曼达。我要告诉她。我要告诉她。主要是因为阿曼达。我爱你，肖恩，但阿曼达，她。不，我懂。
I get it. We all love Amanda. She's pretty great. Will loves Amanda. She's the real boss of this. I think Will talks to Amanda more than I do. Everybody loves Amanda. Well, she has.
我懂。我们都爱阿曼达。她相当棒。威尔爱阿曼达。她才是这里的真正的老板。我觉得威尔跟阿曼达说话比我都多。每个人都爱阿曼达。好吧，她有。
Next fall on NBC. She's my most frequent FaceTimer. But. Wait, wait, Katie, can I go back to, Sean was, I wanna talk about, we talked about you go to Vegas and doing this stuff. What was, for you musically, like what was, I don't know,
今年秋天在 NBC 播出。她是我最频繁进行 FaceTime 通话的人。不过。等等，等等，凯蒂，我能回到——肖恩刚才，我想谈谈，我们聊了你去拉斯维加斯做那些演出。对你来说，在音乐上，比如，我不知道，
who were your idols growing up? Who were the people you're like, I wanna be like that, I wanna sound like that, like this is the kind of shit I wanna do. Jagged Little Pill by Alanis Morse that changed my life. That was the record that changed my life. How old were you when that came out? Well, that's rude ass, but I just.
你成长过程中的偶像是谁？有谁是你觉得“我想成为那样，我想那样唱歌，这就是我想做的音乐”的吗？阿兰尼斯·莫里塞特（Alanis Morissette）的《Jagged Little Pill》改变了我的人生。那是改变我人生的唱片。那张专辑发行时你多大？好吧，这个问题真够粗鲁的，但我只是。
I mean, I'm 37, so I don't know. It was like early 20s or, I mean, that was late teens. Sorry, late teens. God, that was so good. That was a good record. But before that queen, queen was like the, Freddie Mercury was. Yeah, yeah.
我的意思是，我37岁了，所以我不知道。那是20岁出头或者，我的意思是，那是十几岁快结束的时候。对不起，十几岁快结束的时候。天哪，太棒了。那是一张好唱片。但在那之前，皇后乐队（Queen），皇后乐队就像是，弗雷迪·墨丘利（Freddie Mercury）是。对，对。
I only listened to gospel music. I know. The whole life, up until I was about 13, and then I discovered like a greatest hits of Queen and the wide album from the Beatles and Pet Sounds from the Beach Boys. And those three compact discs were on Rotate. That was it.
我只听福音音乐。我知道。我整个人生，直到大约13岁，然后我发现了皇后乐队的精选集、披头士乐队的白色专辑（The White Album）以及海滩男孩（The Beach Boys）的《Pet Sounds》。那三张激光唱片一直在轮流播放。就是这样。
That's amazing. Were you not allowed to listen to other? Oh, that's what I was listening to. Guys, don't fight. Don't fight. John Jinx. No, I wasn't allowed. I was raised in a very Christian,
太惊人了。难道你不被允许听其他的吗？哦，那就是我当时听的。伙计们，别吵架。别吵架。约翰·吉克斯（John Jinx）。不，我不被允许。我在一个非常传统的基督徒家庭长大，
but it's like, they call it born again Christian. So it's like, it's very kind of emotional and like, it's new wave. Don't call it new age, but it's not like, it's not like Catholic. It's like, it's pretty radical Christian. But no music sounds more like boring again. You know what I mean?
但他们管这叫重生基督徒。所以它非常情绪化，而且就像是新潮的。别叫它新时代，但它不像，它不像天主教。它就像是相当激进的基督教。不过，没有什么音乐比重生音乐听起来更无聊了。你知道我的意思吗？
Well, actually there's a whole, like, I mean, there's like all kinds of. You don't have to take that shit from them, Kate. No, she's with me. You're not offending me, please. But no, I grew up with listening to gospel music and Christian music, and there's like a whole, there's a whole Christian music world out there
好吧，其实有一整套，我的意思是，有各种各样的。你用不着忍受他们的废话，凯特。不，她跟我一伙的。你并没有冒犯我，请继续。但不是的，我从小听福音音乐和基督教音乐长大，外面有一个庞大的基督教音乐世界，
that have their own type of Grammys. I mean, it's a whole thing. Yeah, it's huge, right? Yeah, it's massive. Really? Do you mind if I ask how big a religion plays in your life currently? Currently?
他们有自己的格莱美奖。我的意思是，那是一整套体系。对，规模很大，对吧？对，非常庞大。真的吗？你介意我问宗教目前在你生活中占多大比重吗？目前？
Yeah. Religion, organized, no. I don't believe in the way that I was raised. Organized religion is not necessarily for me. I'm a big, big seeker. Orlando is a devout Buddhist, and he chants every morning, mostly. And so I kind of follow a little bit more of his philosophy
对。宗教，有组织的，没有。我不相信我被抚养长大时信仰的那一套。有组织宗教不一定适合我。我是一个非常、非常虔诚的求道者。奥兰多是个虔诚的佛教徒，他几乎每天早上都做早课。所以我某种程度上更追随他的一些哲学，或者仅仅是佛教哲学，但我其实只是这一切的求道者。我的意思是，从神秘主义到数学、几何学再到物理学，还有很多科学。
or just the Buddhist philosophy, but I'm actually just like a seeker of all of it. I mean, like from mysticism to math to geometry to like physics, lots of science. Right, there's something bigger up there that somehow explains all this beautiful, miracle stuff, but what that thing is can be for anybody's choosing kind of thing?
没错，天上肯定有某种更宏大的东西，某种程度上解释了所有这些美丽、奇迹般的的事物，但那东西究竟是什么，可以由任何人自行选择，是这种感觉吗？我的意思是，我确信最终它会是某种东西，我不知道这算不算由谁来选择，但我确信——不，我的意思是，不管他们想管它叫什么，对吧？佛祖还是——我有某些古怪的——也不是古怪，但有些我会去琢磨的想法。我的意思是——
I mean, I'm sure it's ultimately gonna be something, I don't know if it's anyone's choosing, but I'm sure- No, but I mean, whatever they wanna call it, right? Buddha or- I have some freaky, not freaky, but there's some thoughts that I entertain. I mean-
那种能解释这一切的感觉？我的意思是，我对模拟理论很感兴趣。我对NPC（非玩家角色）很感兴趣。当然，说来听听。上周末刚有人带我了解了模拟理论。什么是模拟？你们听说过那个吗？
That explains it all kind of thing? I mean, I'm into simulation theory. I'm into like NPCs. Sure, let's hear all of it. Somebody just walked me through the simulation thing last weekend. What's the simulation? Have you guys heard about that?
好吧，我的意思是，我从来没有被人带了解过。我们是模拟程序的一部分？对，但比如，我弟弟是个狂热的游戏玩家，他对加密货币很感兴趣，我也对加密货币感兴趣之类的事情，但他们昨天在看电子竞技的极限运动。就像是，
Well, I mean, I've never been walked through it. We're a part of a simulation? Yeah, but like for instance, my brother is a big gamer and he's into crypto and I'm into crypto and all that stuff, but they were watching like the X games of video gaming yesterday. And it was like,
画面里简直就是视频游戏玩家坐在电脑前，坐在他们豪华的椅子上玩《FIFA》或者踢足球。然后体育场里坐满了人，看着这些人玩他们的角色、他们的化身。当时我就想，这难道不是已经在发生了吗？这难道是元宇宙中的元宇宙吗？这正在我们身上发生吗？
it was literally just video gamers on their computers with their fancy chairs playing FIFA or playing soccer. And there was a stadium full of people watching these people play their characters, their avatars. And I was like, well, isn't that already happening? Is this like meta, meta? Is this happening with us?
是不是有人在潜在地扮演我们？对。然后我们在琢磨怎么玩另一场游戏。而元宇宙只是我们现实的下一个维度。我不知道。只是某种在我们视野之外的东西。也许这一切都在另一个地方发生着。
Is someone potentially playing us? Right. And then we're figuring out how to play another game. And the metaverse is just like the next dimension of our reality. I don't know. Something just outside of what we can see. And perhaps this is all sort of happening in another place.
我们以为我们在这里，但其实并没有，就是那种感觉。而且我甚至不抽大麻。我甚至不允许抽大麻，因为你不想抽大麻。听起来你好像在胡说八道。我的意思是，你在谈论，听着。听起来我现在好像在微量服用迷幻药。还有一件事要记住。
And we think we're here, but we're really not kind of thing. And I don't even smoke weed. I'm not even allowed to smoke weed because you don't want to smoke weed. It sounds like you're making it. I mean, you're talking about, listen. It sounds like I'm micro dosing now. Here's the other thing to keep in mind.
我也曾有过那种想法，就是那种整件事——我们是不是生活在黑客帝国里？所有那些破事。对，我喜欢这个。老实说，我最近刚刚有过这种想法，在某种程度上，我想，如果真是这样，我其实不想知道，因为意义何在。是的，试着去处理所有这些信息真是相当激烈。
I have had those thoughts too, where it's that whole like, are we in the matrix? All that kind of shit. Yeah, I love that. And I have to be honest, I had it quite recently and to a certain degree, I thought if I am, I actually don't want to know because where's the point. Yes, it's pretty intense to try and process
现在，你刚才说的另一件事是什么？所以是模拟，还有什么是 M.M.T.？不。M.P.C. 那是什么？那是什么？非玩家角色。
any of that information. Now, what was the other thing you said? So simulation and what was your M.M.T.? No. M.P.C. What is that? What is that? Non-player character.
非玩家角色。还有 M.P.C.。就像那部电影《失控玩家》（Free Guy）。肖恩的电影就是讲这个的。背景人物。没有积极参与生活的人。他们就像是，这是一个指代，基本上——我爸爸。
Non-player character. And M.P.C. It's like that free guy movie. That's where Sean's movie was all about that. Background. People that are not actively participating in life. And they're like so, and it's a reference to basically- My dad.
或者凯蒂，如果我错了请纠正我。在视频游戏中四处走动、实际上并不是事情一部分的龙套角色。他们是——哇。我觉得这可能是一种反社会的方式来解释它，但我的意思是，在更深奥的精神层面上，也许它只是指那些缺乏觉知或意识的人。
Or Katie, correct me if I'm wrong. Characters who are extras in video games who just walk around and aren't actually part of the thing. They're- Wow. I think it's maybe a sociopathic way to explain it, but I mean, on a more esoteric spiritual level, maybe it's just people that lack awareness or consciousness.
我觉得一旦那个头显设备、虚拟现实设备——是的，当那个真正普及的时候，我觉得我们会有一堆这样的人。他们会觉得，好吧，我为什么要出门？我有这个完美的虚拟环境，我只需要把它戴在头上。我可以待在我开着空调的房子里，
I feel like as soon as that the headset thing, the virtual reality thing, yeah, when that really takes over, I feel like we're gonna have a bunch of those people. They're just like, well, why should I go out? I got this perfect environment that I could just kind of put on my head. I could stay in my air-conditioned house
而且我真的可以去任何我想去的地方。杰森，你以前做过那个吗？你有没有戴过——没有，但从我听说的情况来看，听起来棒极了。对，因为你一摘下来，你一摘下来就会忘记，哦天哪，我正坐在自己的客厅里。它真的能把你带到另一个世界。
and I can really kind of go wherever I want. Have you done that, Jason, before? Have you put- No, but from what I hear about it, it sounds fantastic. Yeah, because the second you take it off, the second you take it off, you forget, oh gosh, I'm in my living room. It really transports you to another world.
就像是疯狂的体验。但这其实很简单。我们只是来自外星人，句号。就是这样。我们全都是被束缚在肉体中的星星。完全正确。伙计们。我多年来一直这么说。
Like it's crazy. But it's really simple. We're just from aliens, period. That's it. We're all just stars bound to a body. That's exactly right. Guys. I've been saying it for years.
哦等等，凯蒂，我想聊聊你，就聊你一会儿，比如你的歌曲、音乐和一切。我知道我们在聊，但我想谈谈，我只是，你知道的，我太痴迷了。所以首先，我不得不这么说，你知道的，只要我们活着，玛丽亚·凯莉（Mariah Carey）就会有一首圣诞歌曲，
Yeah. Oh wait, Katie, I wanna talk about you just you for a second and like your songs and music and everything. I know we are, but I wanna talk about like, I just, you know, I'm obsessed. So first of all, I just have to say this, you know, for as long as we live, Mariah Carey will have a Christmas song
在每一个假期都会被播放，叫《All I Want For Christmas Is You》，永远如此。而且只有少数人拥有像国歌一样的节日歌曲等等。但只要我们拥有未来的一万年，在独立日（第四季度的节日），人们永远都会在余生中播放凯蒂·佩里的《Firework》。一首伟大的歌。
that will be played every single holiday season called All I Want For Christmas forever. And there's only a handful of people that have anthems like to a holiday and stuff. But for as long as we have the next 10,000 years, fourth of July, they will always play Firework by Katy Perry for the rest of our life. Great song.
我的意思是，这难道不是很酷吗？显然要持续一万年。对，一万年，直到下一次两极磁场翻转。然后所有的流行歌星重新开始。我们这里没有一个人在这个星球上还能再活40年以上。继续，肖恩。对，那就是两极翻转。
I mean, isn't that cool? Apparently for 10,000 years. Yeah, 10,000 years until the next polar shift. Then all the pop stars start over. None of us are living more than 40 more years on this planet. Keep going, Sean. Yeah, that's the polar shift.
不，但这只是，显然。太棒了。我太，听着，我太感激了。我知道，你不用说什么。我只是觉得这太酷了。这太棒了。是的，我的意思是，而且你写它的时候并不是为了那个目的，但它却变成了那种存在。
No, but that's just like, obviously. It's so great. I'm so, look, I'm so grateful. I know, you don't have to say anything. I just think it's so cool. It's the best. Yeah, I mean, and that you didn't write it for that purpose, but it became that thing.
现在每年独立日，我们都能听到那首歌。我觉得这太酷了。我只是觉得这很酷。这太疯狂了，你知道的，你们懂的，因为你们有很多——我的意思是，你们所有人都在成功中度过了很长时间，超过十年了。这就好比在一开始，会有很多焦虑。
And now every fourth of July, we just hear that. I think it's so cool. I just think it's cool. It's wild, you know, you guys know, because you guys have a lot of, I mean, all of you have been in success for a long time, for more than a decade. It's like in the beginning, there's a lot of anxiety
现在每年七月四日，我们都能听到那个声音。我觉得这太酷了。我只是觉得这很酷。这太疯狂了，你知道的，你们也知道，因为你们有很多……我是说，你们所有人都已经成功了很久，超过十年了。这就好比在一开始，会有很多焦虑
and worry and doubt and fear and blah, blah, blah. And then you just keep chipping away, chipping away, chipping away. And then 10 years pass and then 15 years pass. And you're like, oh, this is gonna be okay. I think, yeah, it's gonna be okay. And the more, the more I decide to live, the better I get at living it, you know?
伴随着焦虑、怀疑、恐惧等等乱七八糟的情绪。然后你就不断地坚持，不断地坚持，不断地坚持。接着10年过去了，15年过去了。然后你会想，哦，这会没事的。我想，是的，会没事的。而且我越是决定去生活，我就越擅长生活，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah. The more you decide to live, meaning the less you pay attention to business and the aspirations and the ambition and stuff and more about like personal life you focus on. I mean, yes, but no, I'm just saying that like, you know, I don't come from anything. So I just, I'm grateful that I've been able
对，对。你越是决定去生活，意思是说你越是不那么关注商业、宏伟蓝图和野心之类的事情，而是更多地关注个人生活。我的意思是，算是吧，但也不是，我只是说，你知道的，我出身平凡。所以我只是很感激我能够
to scale these heights. Yeah, yeah. I wouldn't say that I didn't dream of these heights because I totally did. Yeah, yeah. But just because you dream, it doesn't mean you always get the opportunity to do it. Right, but your work ethic, I mean,
攀登到这些高度。对，对。我不会说我没有梦想过达到这些高度，因为我绝对梦想过。对，对。但仅仅因为你有梦想，并不意味着你总能得到实现它的机会。没错，但你的职业道德，我是说，
it's like song after song, album after album is just massively globally huge. It's just unbelievable. Thank you. You know, where does that come from? Where are you just like, you know what? I gotta get another album and another album and another album and all the people that you collaborate with.
简直是一首接一首的歌，一张接一张的专辑，在全球范围内都获得了巨大的成功。这简直难以置信。谢谢你。你知道，这源于哪里？是什么让你觉得，你知道吗？我得再出一张专辑，再出一张专辑，再出一张专辑，还有所有跟你合作的那些人。
Childhood trauma. Yeah, for sure. Childhood trauma, it is the gasoline for all art for a long, long time until it turns against you. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now, what does it look like? What does it look like in another 15 years?
童年创伤。是的，肯定的。童年创伤，它是所有艺术长久以来的汽油，直到它开始反噬你。我们马上回来。现在，欢迎回到节目中。那么，接下来会是什么样？再过15年，会是什么样？
Is there, would you love to just become a more and more mature singer, a songwriter, a producer or all of it? You know, my currency is communication with people. You know, that's what I feel like I'm put on the planet to do. Yeah, you're an excellent communicator. I watch an American Idol the way you speak
有没有，你会不会渴望成为一个越来越成熟的歌手、词曲作者、制作人，还是所有这些集于一身？你知道，我的通用货币是与人们的交流。你知道，我觉得这就是我被带到这个星球上要做的事情。是的，你是一个极好的沟通者。我看《美国偶像》时，看你说话的方式
to the contestants. I've seen you in interviews, the way you just speak, the way you carry yourself is extremely intelligent, very succinct, very- Sean, go ahead and ask her. He wants to know how much you make on American Idol. He's desperate to know. And by the way, he's laughing now
对选手们。我见过你接受采访，你说话的方式，你的举止极其聪明，非常简练，非常——肖恩，快去问她。他想知道你在《美国偶像》里赚了多少钱。他极想知道。顺便说一句，他现在在笑，
and he's also like, but maybe she will. Scratching the question off the list. No, but seriously. So I'd like to continue scaling with that. I mean, I love music and that has been the main, that's my main tree, but I have a ton of branches and maybe another tree. By the way, what about acting?
而且他也觉得，不过也许她会说呢。把这个问题从清单上划掉。不，但说真的。所以我想继续在这方面攀登。我的意思是，我热爱音乐，那是主要的，那是我的主树，但我有很多枝桠，也许还有另一棵树。顺便问一下，演戏怎么样？
Because in all your videos, I swear I'm not just saying this, you're a really talented actress and I can't be the first person to tell you. But in every video, I'm just like, why is she not like in a movie or something? Or like a TV show? Can I tell you?
因为在你所有的视频里，我发誓我不是随便说说的，你真的是个很有才华的女演员，我肯定不是第一个这么对你说的人。但在每一个视频里，我都在想，为什么她不演电影什么的？或者像电视剧？我能告诉你吗？
Can I tell you? Yeah, let's make some news. So... You and Orly are doing love letters. You're doing love letters down at the get- No, I respect what you guys do, but I think I have a little bit more fun. Oh, wow.
我能告诉你吗？好吧，让我们来爆点新闻。所以……你和奥利正在做情书（节目）。你们在——不，我尊重你们做的事，但我认为我更有乐趣。哦，哇。
You probably do. Sorry, sorry. Because I have been on set. I have, you know, I've been around all the actors. I've dated them, married them, blah, blah, blah, blah. And like the amount of time that you guys sit in a trailer and then the amount of deliveries and takes you do like close up and then wide
你可能确实更有趣。抱歉，抱歉。因为我呆过片场。我，你知道的，我周围都是演员。我和他们约会过，结过婚，等等等等。像你们在房车里坐的时间，然后你们拍特写、中景时要拍多少个镜头和条数，
and over the shoulder. And it's just like, I just go on the stage for two hours and I do it all in real time in front of a real audience. And, you know, I feel like I love what I do. And like I would not, not do a movie. Obviously I have ideas and dreams and I probably will in the future, but it has to be something that I'm totally like
还有过肩镜头。这就好像，我只需要上台两个小时，在真正的观众面前实时完成这一切。而且，你知道，我觉得我热爱我做的事。而且我不会说绝对不拍电影。显然我有一些想法和梦想，我以后可能会拍，但那必须是我完全感到
so excited for and develop and own and all that jazz. Because I'm, you know, it's a real communal job that you guys have. And my job takes a team, but it's not as communal. Like the buck stops at me. Yeah, yeah, that's cool. So I'm like, I love watching films. I love, you know, I respect and admire
非常兴奋、并且能够参与开发和拥有的作品，诸如此类。因为我，你知道的，你们的工作是一个真正的集体工作。我的工作需要一个团队，但没有那么集体化。就像最终拍板的人是我。对，对，那挺酷的。所以我只是觉得，我喜欢看电影。我喜欢，你知道的，我尊重、钦佩
and I'm in awe of the dedication, the time spent, the effort that all y'all do. But it's just, it's a lot. Yeah, but you're in the studio for hours and days and weeks and then you shoot videos for hours and days and weeks. No, the videos are just a couple of days, right? Videos are two to three days.
并惊叹于你们所有人所付出的奉献、花费的时间和努力。但它确实，很多。是的，但你在录音室里呆上几个小时、几天、几周，然后你拍视频也要花上几个小时、几天、几周。不，视频只要几天，对吧？视频只要两到三天。
All right. Well, calm down, everybody. Well, no, no, no, I'm, I'm, I was looking up, Katie, I was looking at, I was trying to remember the name of your song. Anyway, I was just looking up. Give me some context clues, I'll tell you. Well, no, it was Roar.
好吧。好吧，大家冷静点。好吧，不，不，不，我，我，我刚才在查，凯蒂，我在查，我正努力想记起你那首歌的名字。总之，我刚才在查。给我一些上下文线索，我告诉你。好吧，不，是《Roar》。
Sing a little bit of it. Roar, yeah. But then the question is this, well, it's more of a statement. So then Wikipedia decides to tell me that you've sold over 143 million records worldwide. You've had over a billion streams on Spotify. You have nine number one US singles.
唱一小段。Roar，是的。但问题是这样的，好吧，这更像是一个陈述。然后维基百科告诉我，你在全球售出了超过1.43亿张唱片。你在Spotify上的流媒体播放量超过了10亿次。你有9首美国公告牌冠军单曲。
I'm like, what? That's what I'm saying. That's what I said. So when you're saying to her, do you ever want to be an actress? She's like, what? Why the fuck would I go and do what you do, you tool? I'm gonna, she's like on top of a mountain.
我都惊呆了。这就是我要说的。这就是我说的。所以当你在对她说，你有没有想过当演员？她的反应是，什么？我他妈为什么要去做你做的事，你这个白痴？我打算，她就像站在山顶上一样。
No, it's an artistic medium. Yes, no, but have you seen her videos? She's like a really fantastic actress. Yes, I have seen her videos. I don't disagree. It's amazing. That's what I'm saying. If you have a two year old, it'll start eventually. Yeah, well.
不，这是一种艺术媒介。是的，不，但是你看过她的视频吗？她就像一个非常出色的演员。是的，我看过她的视频。我并不否认。这太棒了。这就是我要说的。如果你有个两岁的孩子，最终也会变成这样。好吧，好吧。
Okay, so wait, before we let you go, because it's been too long and you're gonna get back to it. You're narrating an Elizabeth Taylor podcast, which is amazing. Tell me about why and what it's about. And Elizabeth Taylor, you only talk about Elizabeth Taylor, I don't understand. Well, I'm learning so much by narrating it.
好吧，等等，在我们让你离开之前，因为时间已经不早了，你还得回去继续工作。你正在为一个伊丽莎白·泰勒的播客担任旁白，这太棒了。告诉我为什么要做这个，以及它讲的是什么。而且伊丽莎白·泰勒，你只谈伊丽莎白·泰勒，我不太明白。嗯，我在担任旁白的过程中学到了很多。
She's like one of my heroes. I mean, she just, you know, she wasn't just an actress. She was an activist and expanded. She was the first influencer, I would say, you know, she created a brand and, you know, she had ownership. She really was such an incredible business woman. And, you know, I'm just so inspired by her and I resonate a lot with her story
她就像我的偶像之一。我的意思是，她，你知道的，她不仅仅是一个演员。她还是一个活动家，并且拓展了影响力。我想说，她是第一个网红，你知道的，她创造了一个品牌，并且，你知道的，她拥有所有权。她真的是一个如此不可思议的女商人。而且，你知道，我深受她的启发，我和她的故事有很多共鸣，
and hope to, you know, have as many husbands as her. So, you know, what did she have seven? It's a seven and one of them was twice. I don't know. Yeah, that was Richard Burton. Wow, old Dickie Burtz. Yeah. Oh my God. At what point do you think she said, maybe it's me.
并希望，你知道的，能和她一样结那么多次婚。所以，你知道，她结过多少次？七次？是七次，其中有一次结了两次。我不知道。是的，那是理查德·伯顿。哇，老迪基·伯茨。哦，天哪。你觉得她在哪个时间点会说，也许问题出在我身上。
But anyway, okay. But last stat that I think is so impressive and I couldn't name a million of them is of all halftime Super Bowl shows, yours is the most watched. Worth it. I think it's incredible. Well deserved. Thank you. I thought it was amazing.
但无论如何，好吧。不过最后一个我认为非常惊艳的数据，我可说不出其中的好几百万个，那就是在所有的超级碗中场秀中，你的观看人数是最多的。实至名归。我认为这太不可思议了。实至名归。谢谢你。我觉得太棒了。
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Was it worth it? Can you know when they talk about, like, they're all like, this year in the Super Bowl, it's gonna be Katy Perry and then they're like, did you guys hear in this weekend, this year in the Super Bowl, it's gonna be so-and-so. Was it that much of a thrill?
嗯嗯，嗯嗯。这值得吗？你知道当他们谈论时，就像，他们都会说，今年的超级碗将是凯蒂·帕瑞，然后他们会说，你们听说了吗这个周末，今年的超级碗将是某某某。这是一种极大的刺激吗？
You can be honest, because nobody listens to this podcast. Yeah. You guys are actually really popular. I thought that it was really fun, all the apparatus about it. Was it fun? So was it everything that you wanted it to,
你可以说实话，因为没人听这个播客。是的。你们其实挺受欢迎的。我觉得这真的很有趣，关于它的所有设备和装置。有趣吗？所以这符合你所有的期望吗，
is it the greatest thing? Yeah, yeah, it was everything. It was like, it was really intense. It was the most adrenaline. It was like, I had never been close to death. I had never given birth, so I had nothing to compare it to those feelings. Seemed like really intense life feelings,
这是最棒的事情吗？是的，是的，它就是一切。它就像是，真的非常激烈。那是最大的肾上腺素飙升。这就像，我从未离死亡这么近。我从未生过孩子，所以我没有什么可以拿来跟那种感觉作比较。感觉像是非常强烈的人生体验，
but it felt like it was in that same category. You don't really wish it on anyone, but it's a rite of passage in some ways, and it separates, I think, people, and it definitely helps catapult and just puts you in a different thing. And it was amazing, and I got to pick my people that I performed with,
但感觉它属于同一种范畴。你不会真的希望任何人去经历这个，但在某种程度上，这是一次成人礼，我认为它能将人们区分开来，而且它绝对有助于你的事业腾飞，把你推向一个不同的境界。这太棒了，而且我能挑选跟我一起表演的人，
which was Missy Elliott and Lenny Kravitz, but I rehearsed the hell out of it. You did. Well, one of my producers for that particular show, he literally had a cattle prod, and he would run after me with this cattle prod, and it'd just go, and it was like, my legs were so sore,
那就是米莉·埃利奥特和兰尼·克拉维茨，但我为了它进行了地狱般的彩排。确实如此。嗯，那场特定演出的一位制片人，他手里拿着一根类似驱牛棒的东西，他会拿着这个驱牛棒追着我跑，嘴里发出滋滋的声音，就好像，我的腿酸得要命，
but I had to climb and mount that lion again. And get on it. And what you didn't see in between all the changes and stuff on that particular show is that I was coming down from the lion by literally holding onto a fire pole. So I was like, coming down the fire pole, I was changing, ripping things.
但我不得不再次爬上去骑上那只狮子。然后站上去。在那个特定节目的各种换装和转场之间，你没看到的是，我其实是抓着一根消防钢管滑下来的。所以我当时就像是在滑消防钢管，边滑边换衣服，把衣服撕掉。
I was wearing three costumes under one thing. There was so much behind the scenes that was going on in order to give it that color and variety and life, and just have it be the biggest thing. How long did they let you rehearse that? I don't know, I rehearsed it for months on end, but. Really months?
我一件衣服里面套了三套服装。为了呈现那种色彩、多样性、生命力，并让它成为最震撼的表演，幕后有太多事情在进行。他们让你排练了多久？我不知道，我连续排练了好几个月，但是。真的好几个月？
Yeah, but you only get like, there's so much room for error in that show. Yeah, of course, it's only like 10 minutes, right? 10, 12 minutes, yeah. And a lot of my show was based on projection. So the funny thing will not funny. I do a lot of projecting too. Yeah, I guess.
对，但你只有，那场演出出错的空间太小了。对，当然，只有大概10分钟吧？10到12分钟，对。而且我的很多演出都是基于投影的。所以有趣的是——也不是有趣。我也做了很多投影。对，我想也是。
No, but like, it has to get, the light has to be a certain way in order for projection to work. And that game was running early. So I was about to get totally screwed. And something happened, the universe covered me, and there were some calls or fouls or whatever that were called that delayed the game.
不，但是，灯光必须达到某种特定的效果，投影才能正常运作。而那场比赛当时进展得比较快。所以我差点就要彻底搞砸了。结果发生了点意外，上天保佑了我，比赛中出现了一些犯规或其他判罚，导致比赛延误了。
And finally, it got dark enough that the projection would actually be read. Otherwise, I was gonna have a pretty crappy show. Wow, that's so much pressure. And so you're building up, you're rehearsing, then stuff like that happens. And it sort of occurs to me. I mean, not only do you have to go and do it,
最后，天终于黑到足够让投影显现出来了。否则，我的演出就要变得一团糟了。哇，压力太大了。你一直在筹备、排练，然后遇到这种状况。这让我突然意识到，我的意思是，不仅你得去完成它，
but you are, especially because you're a solo artist. I know there are a lot of people who you work with and a lot of dancers and people, of course, but it's you, it's your name. And you're the CEO of Katy Perry, Inc. And you're also the star. Katy Perry, Inc. Yeah, you know what I mean?
而且你，特别是作为一个独唱艺人。我知道有很多跟你合作的人，还有很多舞者之类的人，当然，但这是你，这是你的名字。你是Katy Perry公司的CEO。而你也是明星。Katy Perry公司。对，你知道我的意思吗？
But you're all, everybody's leaning on you. There must be, that's a lot of, must be a lot of pressure. When the call comes in, they're like, hey, Katy, they want you to do a Super Bowl. Are you like, yes, automatically? Are you like, huh, this is risky? You have to make all these big decisions, is my point.
但每个人、所有人都依仗着你。那一定，压力一定很大。当电话打来，他们说，嘿，Katy，他们想让你去表演超级碗。你是不是立刻就答应了？还是会想，嗯，这会不会太冒险？我的意思是，你必须做出所有这些重大决定。
It's a lot, I bet. Big risk, big reward. Looks right, yeah, that's right. I like to roll it. I mean, it's admirable as hell. But I like to roll it with preparation. So when I decide to do something, I'm a super prepper. It's not by accident.
这确实很多，我敢说。高风险，高回报。听起来对，没错。我喜欢冒险。我的意思是，这真是太令人钦佩了。但我喜欢带着充分的准备去冒险。所以当我决定要做某事时，我是一个超级做准备的人。这绝不是偶然。
So there's no nerves ever for anything. Like opening the show in Vegas, I had been developing it for over a year. I had been on stage rehearsing it for months on end. I had everything dialed in. There were no surprises. The only thing we were navigating in that time was COVID. And we were bobbing and weaving left and right
所以从来没有什么事会让我紧张。比如在拉斯维加斯开场的那场演出，我筹备了一年多。我已经在舞台上连续排练了好几个月。我把一切都调整到了最佳状态。没有任何意外。我们当时唯一需要应付的是新冠疫情。我们在左躲右闪、左右周旋，
because it was such a crazy time. But the preparation makes the precision. Yeah, for sure. I like that. Yeah, and it shows in everything you do. Every single thing you do is like perfection. Thanks, John. I really appreciate you.
因为那是个太疯狂的时期。但充分的准备造就了精准。对，确实如此。我喜欢这样。是的，这体现在你做的每一件事上。你做的每一件事简直都堪称完美。谢谢，Jason。我真的很感激。
It's true. Yeah, you're drilling it. You're absolutely killing it. It's amazing. Katie, we love you. Thank you for being here. Please go and tend to your daughter. Thanks for doing this and taking some time out
是真的。对，你太拿手了。你简直绝了。这太惊艳了。Katy，我们爱你。谢谢你来这里。请去照顾你的女儿吧。谢谢你抽空，
from being mommy and please say hi to daddy. I will, I will. And please say hi to other mommy, Amanda. I will, I definitely will. Love her. Thanks, guys. Thank you, Katie. Can I give a shout out to my cousin, Jen,
从当妈妈的日常中抽身出来，请代我向爸爸问好。我会的，我会的。请代我向另一个妈妈Amanda问好。我会的，我一定会的。代我向她问好。谢谢你们。谢谢你，Katy。我能对我的表妹Jen大声表白吗，
who listens to your podcast and she's the reason why I ultimately said yes. Jen. Thanks to Jen. Thanks, Jen. She's a huge, she's a huge fan. Where's Jen? Where's Jen?
她听你们的播客，她也是我最终答应来这里的理由。Jen。谢谢Jen。谢谢Jen。她是你们的超级大粉丝。Jen在哪？Jen在哪？
Jen is in LA and she just conquered breast cancer. So, huge, huge fan of you guys. And I, she was telling me about smart list and then someone said, oh, you should do smart list. And I was like, oh, well, my cousin really likes it and she's cool, so I'm gonna do it. But I also like you guys. Very nice.
Jen在洛杉矶，她刚刚战胜了乳腺癌。所以，她绝对是你们的超级大粉丝。她之前跟我提起过SmartLess，然后有人说，哦，你应该去上SmartLess。我就想，哦，我表妹真的很喜欢，而且她人很好，所以我要去。但我也很喜欢你们。太好了。
That's awesome. Well, send, please send our love to Jen. We're saying it right now. Jen, we're sending you our love. Jen, we love you. Yeah, we do love you. We're happy for you. Congrats, it's awesome.
太棒了。那么，请把我们的爱带给Jen。我们现在就在说。Jen，我们把爱送给你。Jen，我们爱你。对，我们真的很爱你。为你感到高兴。恭喜，这太棒了。
We love you too, Katie. Woo, love you guys. Thanks for doing it. All right, bye. Oh, I forgot to tell her to text me. She's never gonna text me. You know, just text her? Text her, yeah.
我们也很爱你，Katy。呜，爱你们。谢谢你们来。好了，再见。噢，我忘让她给我发短信了。她永远都不会给我发短信。你知道的，就给她发个短信？发短信，对。
Text her. I don't know, I don't know. And wait for the bubbles. Could you imagine? If I had her digits, that's what you guys say. If I had her digits, I would be texting her all day and night. Just like a bunch of like kitties on skateboards and stuff, I just make her just throw her phone
发短信。我不知道，我不知道。然后等着对话气泡出现。你能想象吗？如果我有她的号码，这就是你们常说的。如果我有她的号码，我就会整天整夜给她发短信。就像发一堆滑滑板的小猫之类的表情，我只想让她气得把手机
out the window. Just kooky stuff all day and night. I didn't know that she and Amanda were friends. She is, she has talked with Amanda quite a few times. I didn't know that. Dinners and stuff with Orlando and, you know, Amanda, Amanda. Amanda knows everybody. Amanda knows the house at night.
扔出窗外。整天整夜发一些古怪的东西。我不知道她和Amanda是朋友。她是的，她和Amanda聊过好几次。我不知道这个。跟奥兰多一起吃过晚饭什么的，你知道的，Amanda，Amanda。Amanda认识所有人。Amanda连晚上谁家灯亮着都知道。
I do not, you know, I'm a house cat. But how great is she? It's not a nice surprise. I've never had a lengthy conversation with her. I just said hello once and then she came on the phone. No, I don't know her at all. Oh, oh. I just met her once so fast.
我不知道，你知道的，我是个家猫。但她人多好啊？这不是个惊喜吗？我从来没有跟她进行过长谈。我只是打过一次招呼，然后她就接电话了。不，我一点也不了解她。哦，哦。我只见过她一次，而且非常快。
It was so brief. We did like a bit with like, you know. They should have been in the interview. God, we're bad interviewers. We're the worst. Oh, my God. Well, we're not smart. You know, if we were smart, we'd ask good questions.
太短暂了。我们就像是演了一段小品，你知道的。他们本来应该参与采访的。天哪，我们真是不合格的采访者。我们是最差的。哦，天哪。好吧，我们并不聪明。你知道的，如果我们聪明的话，就会问出好问题。
I know. We do research. I know. But it just occurred to me when she was talking about it. This goes for all solo artists, but just, you know, how much pressure there is on her. Like, you know, it's insane. It's incredible.
我懂。我们做了功课。我懂。但刚才她谈到这个时，我突然想到。这适用于所有独唱艺人，但只是，你知道的，她身上承受了多少压力。就像是，你知道的，这太疯狂了。这太不可思议了。
By the way, I did this huge enterprise. I know. Well, you know, there's a lot of pressure on you too, Arnette. Who's the CEO of Will Arnette? I know, but you know what I mean? Like, yeah, but I'm not Katy Perry, man. She's on a, you know, she's killing it. Yeah.
顺便说一句，我做了这么大的一番事业。我知道。好吧，你知道的，Arnette，你身上也有很大压力。谁是Will Arnette公司的CEO？我知道，但你知道我的意思吗？就像是，对，但我不是Katy Perry，老兄。她正处于，你知道的，她太厉害了。对。
I don't know. I mean, let's do it. Sing Roar one more time. You're going to hear me roar. You're going to hear me roar. Just take on me. What about, what about? I do like that song so catchy.
我不知道。我的意思是，我们来唱一遍。再唱一遍Roar。You're going to hear me roar。You're going to hear me roar。那Take on me呢？那首呢，那首呢？我确实很喜欢那首歌，太洗脑了。
So, like, how does the fire? She said nine, number one U.S. singer. How does the firecracker one go? It goes, firecracker, wait, wait. And I can't think of it. Of course, I know it's not. You light it and I will spark it. Is that, am I close?
那么，那个火是怎样的？她说，全美排名第一的歌手。那个“火爆浪子（firecracker）”那首是怎么唱的？它是这样的，火爆浪子，等等，等等。我想不起来了。当然，我知道不是那个。You light it and I will spark it。是这样吗，我猜得接近吗？
Who is you? Start this fuse and I will bang, bang, bang it. That's it for you. Listen to the style of music. You get too much Paul Anka in your life. If I close my eyes, Katy Perry never left. Every song that Jason Singh sounds like a Paul Anka yet. You are the one.
Who is you？Start this fuse and I will bang, bang, bang it。就是这样。听听这种音乐风格。你生活中听了太多Paul Anka的歌了。如果我闭上眼睛，感觉Katy Perry从未离开。Jason Singh唱的每首歌听起来都像Paul Anka。You are the one。
Wait, how does fire work though? Oh yeah, wait, I have it here and look, and it says, firework written by. By. Katy Perry. Beautiful, all time best, right there. That was the best one. Smart.
等等，不过烟花（firework）是怎么样的？噢，对了，等下，我有这个，你看，上面写着，Firework词曲作者。作者。Katy Perry。太美了，史上最佳，就在这。那是最好的一首。聪明。
Nice. Smart, nice. Smart, nice. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbago. SmartLess. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好。聪明，好。聪明，好。SmartLess是由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf和Bennett Barbago 100%有机手工打造的。SmartLess。本集目前还没有评论。点击节目文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。